adam's on the help
and you just heard you just heard uh
coach van gundy say stay down below
he's got a couple on his first two from
beyond the arc
bradley be to get on the wheel and a lot
of times all it takes is the shooter to
see one go in
it's an excellent set play but that's
bi's first attempt inside the
three-point line
it'll be the mid-range game of bradley
beal the second all-time leading scorer
in team history at times it sounds crazy
to say but
that is a tough shot but i i don't know
it it's your
the thought process is a little
different a heck of a move by bradley
beal
when you get the ball up and you have an
advantage it changes things
contact it's a heck of an offensive
player right there off the wrong foot
too
this guy had 60 by the way just about
three weeks ago
and you said it now close the way you
started close
close the right way jordan bell good
break
and that's what makes bradley bill so
good off the ball right so he's stuck on
five
beal on a little fall away boy he's got
a sweet stroke
boy does he he does such a good job of
creating space so nedo out there
the lead guard would bradley build at
the two and lonzo is doubtful
on coming back after tweaking his ankle
as bradley beal
he can get him back into the game in a
hurry boy he's going to be able to do
what he loves
again great news he said the screening
saved his life
it'll be bradley beal all the way to the
rack and all the way to the free throw
line of the foul from behind by bledsoe
bradley bill let's take a step back
because he's too fast to try and stop
him at the point of contact
so whether it's a pick and roll or right
there as a dribble handoff as opposed
as opposed to settling
see you see the cushion that steven
adams is giving him and then he's just
putting a hand up and if a guy hits that
shot
more power to him he's that good of a
passer
field natural
bradley field is up to 27. gave stephen
adams an opportunity to take that ball
in because
he took robin lopez out to play with his
penetration bradley beal
boy lowered the dribble didn't he got
through the traffic see you there
bradley beal gets to the rim didn't get
the finish
bradley beal how about that lead
robinson and he's going to the line
of basketball throw the ball straight to
him he threw him so he had an
opportunity to run into it
that's a heck of a lead pass and really
good friend finished by bradley
he looks good man he's lost so much
weight it's wild
it'll be bradley beal and if you see
that right there he
faked the back door
and you can see everything they're doing
right now is for bradley bill
how good is bradley it's like a video
game man is he good
good and reward him for getting to the
foul line good health defense but it
came back to beale
and if you're nikhil you're the one guy
that can't help
and i like what he's doing like i'm not
worried about anybody else
go on caches winston do your thing back
door run though and beale gets the easy
one
you relax they're going to burn you yeah
so inside of 10 on the shot clock 45
already for beale
he's too good and make it 47. he slides
right by nikhil